YURI GRINSHTEYN: Do you
run distributed workloads
on Kubernetes or GKE?
If so, you are probably
having to manage
more and more services, and
it's getting harder or harder
to understand what's going
on if there are any issues.
This is where a
service mesh can help.
A service mesh is a dedicated
infrastructure layer
that you can add
to your clusters.
It gives you a capabilities
like observability, traffic
management, and
security, without having
to modify application code.
My name is Yuri.
I'm an SRE at Google Cloud.
And today I'm going to show you
how to use both the open source
version of the
Istio service mesh
and Google's managed
Anthos Service Mesh
to get better observability for
your services running a GKE.
This is Engineering
for Reliability.
[LIGHT MUSIC]
The Istio service mesh works
by adding Envoy proxy sidecars
to your services running on GKE.
These proxies intercept all
service-to-service traffic
in the mesh and enable the
application-aware features
like security, traffic
management and routing,
and observability.
This is the data plane.
The control plane dynamically
programs the proxy
sidecars, updating them as
the rules or the environment
change.
Your first option for
using Istio in GKE
is to simply install
the open source
distribution in your cluster.
This is the way to
go if you prefer
to have the most control
over your deployment
or if you have existing
dependencies on features that
may not yet be available in
Google's managed offering.
Istio includes an open
source observability toolkit.
You can use Prometheus for
metrics and Zipkin or Jaeger
for analyzing tracing.
You can also enable
proxy access logs
and have the proxy
sidecars write out logs
for every request in the mesh.
Let's have a look at how
you can use this toolkit
and centralize all that
telemetry to Cloud Operations.
In our example, we have
an application running
in the Istio demo namespace.
We have the Istio control plane
and observability components
running in the Istio
system namespace.
This includes Prometheus
for metrics and Kiali
for observing
traffic in the mesh.
If, for example, we want
to look at the request
rate for our
services in the mesh,
we can use the istioctl
dashboard prometheus command
and run a query like this.
If we want to
visualize how traffic
flows between the different
services in the mesh,
we can use Kiali.
At each node we can see how much
traffic the service is seeing
and what the response
time looks like.
Finally, we can enable request
logging for the Envoy side car
proxies by using
a telemetry API.
We can then view those
logs in the terminal.
Now let's have a look at how
we can get this telemetry
into Cloud Operations.
To adjust the
Prometheus metrics,
we can actually use Google's
Managed Prometheus binary just
by replacing this image tag.
This allows us to query
Prometheus metrics
in Metrics Explorer.
Here's that same
request for a query.
The proxy sidecar request
logs are automatically
ingested into Cloud Logging.
And we can query those, too.
So through the combination
of Google's Managed Service
for Prometheus
and Cloud Logging,
we can get metric and
log telemetry generated
by Istio ingested
into Cloud Operations
and use it just
like other telemetry
from your infrastructure
and services.
If you want to maximize control
over your Istio deployment
and possibly have experience
with Istio already,
using the open
source distribution
is the right way to go.
However, if you're new
to using a service mesh
or would simply like a
more managed experience,
there's the Anthos
Service Mesh or ASM.
It's a tested and supported
distribution of Istio,
giving you all the
benefits of a service mesh
with full Google support.
If you'd like to
control version upgrades
yourself or have existing
integrations you depend on,
you can deploy ASM with an
in-cluster control plane.
Let's have a look
at such a deployment
and how it automatically sends
telemetry to Cloud Operations.
Let's first have a
look at our cluster.
The control plane pods are
running in the Istio system
namespace, just like what we had
when we installed open source
Istio.
Our application pods are also
instrumented with the Istio
proxy containers.
Now let's have a
look at the telemetry
that the Anthos
Service Mesh collects.
The Anthos Service Mesh home
page in the Cloud Console
has a list of the
services that are running
in the mesh in our cluster.
We can select a service and
get some basic information
about it, like request
rates, error rate,
and average latency.
The topology view here
shows us how the service
sends and receives traffic.
The Metrics screen allows
us to see these metrics
over time, broken down
by various dimensions.
Finally, we can get error
logs for our service
by going to the
Diagnostics screen.
We can click out to
the Logs Explorer
to get more details
about these error logs.
This is also where we
can view the access logs
for our services.
We can get more metrics
telemetry in Cloud Monitoring.
example, we can run
a query like this
to get a breakdown of
request rates by service.
So this is how you can use
telemetry automatically
ingested from the
in-cluster ASM control plane
to understand the behavior and
the health of your services.
If you're just
starting out with Istio
or would like to use a
fully managed service,
you can use Managed ASM.
In this deployment
model, the control plane
is fully managed by Google and
does not run in your cluster.
It does mean that some features,
like custom metric adapters,
won't work.
If you need advanced
features like these,
the open source distribution
may be the way to go for you.
If not, let's have a look
at a managed ASM deployment
and how its telemetry
is automatically
ingested into Cloud Operations.
Let's again start by
looking at our cluster.
In this case, we don't actually
have any Istio control plane
pods running in the
Istio system namespace.
The control plane is
entirely managed by Google,
and there are no
control plane components
running in the cluster itself.
Our application paths,
however, are still
instrumented with the Istio
proxy sidecar container.
Now let's have a look at
the collected telemetry.
Just like before, we
can look at the services
running in our cluster.
For all of them, we can get
the same basic telemetry,
including the topology view.
We can get the same
metric telemetry,
and we can get the
same access logs.
All of this is made available
via the managed control
plane without the
need to have anything
running in the cluster itself.
Thanks so much for
watching today.
We learned how a service
mesh improves observability
for distributed
workloads run in GKE
and how you can use Cloud
Operations to get telemetry
from both open source Istio
and the Anthos Service Mesh
to observe your own services.
I hope this helps you to keep
your applications reliable
and your users happy.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more "Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud."
See you soon.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]